hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et tu table le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais franchement
on va tenter un petit concert là il va
falloir vraiment que micro bougez pas je
suis sûr vous vous tenez à mes propres
pc ou un petit peu quand même
on va faire les tâches non mais c'est en
effet pas vous tapez sur les fans ont pu
à bas alors on fait les choses alors des
temps je me détends nuit contre tout le
temps dans le temps c'est une chanson
enfantine au clair de la lune à la tri
mais le haut niveau des intentions à man
dans les annales
[Applaudissements]
je voulais il avait compris qu'il allait